desde primera hora de la mañana
numerosos simpatizantes de Donald Trump
se han agolpado en los exteriores de la
corte Federal aquí en el centro de la
ciudad de Miami para expresar su apoyo
al ex mandatario y denunciar según ellos
que esto se trata de una maniobra
política para evitar que se quedó en el
Trump se presentan las elecciones de
2024 al mediodía una hora antes de esa
comparecencia ante el juez Donald Trump
ha salido de su club de golf en Doral a
unos 20 minutos del centro de Miami y se
ha dirigido hasta aquí con la Caravana
numerosos simpatizantes lo han seguido
también a lo largo de ese trayecto hasta
esta sede judicial y ha entrado a en un
parking subterráneo por lo que la imagen
de la entrada caminando a esta corte
Federal no ha sido posible después se
han hecho los protocolos que requieren
la corte Federal las huellas dactilares
las fotos protocolarias y ha empezado
ese ese esa audiencia donde se le han
leído formalmente los 37 cargos a los
que deberá hacer frente en este proceso
penal 31 de esos cargos son
efectivamente la ley de espionaje de
Estados Unidos El que tiene que ver con
la retención de información sobre
defensa nacional cualquier tipo de
documento que de alguna manera pueda
perjudicar a Estados Unidos ya a algunos
de esos documentos 31 de esos documentos
estaban marcados como secreto o top
Secret y lo que dice la ley es que
poseer este tipo de documentos ya por si
pues se pueden presentar cargos de este
de este tipo